a region r is bounded by the curves
right there's nothing nothing else no
other information that you need
there is the only region that is bounded
sufficiently by the curves okay a couple
of you tried to go
with a coordinate axis and inevitably
got confused because you get an infinite
area and so an infinite volume so you
have to find the coordinates that wasn't
too hard
when you solve you've got one two
three points and the coordinates are
minus 220 0
12 2 4. okay so where were the marks
one marked for solving these
simultaneously which gave you x values
the second mark was for them putting it
back into either of the equations
you know if you're smart that one to get
your y values
one month for actually getting these
graphs decent looking
okay so you had to have curvature and
all that kind of thing in a reasonable
sense
and then the last mark was for getting
that region right
x y graphs
regions four marks right and easy four
to start you off
now part two you then had to find the
volume and
it was prescribed for you which method
you had to use
by taking cylindrical shells show that
the volume
generated by going around the y-axis
is and then there's the number okay now
this part wasn't necessary
but like i said when you didn't do it or
you did it badly you sort of
really hurt yourself the volume i'm
gonna get is going around here
okay so firstly i mean i could draw the
entire volume but it's just gonna get
confusing
okay so instead what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to take
one cylindrical shell right now when
you've got shells
are the slices sorry are the areas
parallel to the axis of rotation or
perpendicular which way
they're parallel right so i'm going to
get an up down kind of
area that's going to become the shell
right so when i rotate this around
like so here's what i get
okay there you go and you can see it on
the photocopy right
now what proceeds from there is i was
looking for number one first mark
the actual volume expression okay now
can you see by the way
see how on my diagram i can see
what the height is supposed to be it's
quite obviously that's the height okay
some of you went straight to saying look
i can consider this as an unfolded you
know
cut up cylindrical shell which goes to
this right but then you might have
gotten some of your dimensions confused
which would have confused your integral
okay so when i see it here
i have a look and i think well clearly
it's going to be
one graph minus the other right at least
for this one that i've taken
and i'm going to consider just one half
of it because there's symmetry here
the cubic graph is on top of the linear
graph
right so i'm going to subtract this from
this
this from this so that's how i get 4x
minus
x cubed okay can you see that the 12s
cancel
there's going to be a double negative on
that negative 4 so that's why it becomes
4x minus x cubed
so therefore i can say i can put in my
summation statement okay
the volume is equal to the limit
okay which way are my slices again sorry
my areas
a good diagram helps you out because
look i can see that's the width i'm
interested in right
and look i threw it in horizontally so
clearly it's delta x
okay so i'm going to take the limit as
delta x approaches zero off
okay now where shall i add up what are
my boundaries going to be
okay and he had a couple of choices here
the way i went about it was i said
i'm going to consider it from zero to
two
from zero to two
okay i could go from minus two to 2 but
i'm going to take advantage of the
symmetry of this
to halve the value that i've got i'm
going to integrate and it gives me a
nice easy thing to punch into my
integral
okay you do need to justify that so when
i finish this line
here's my 2 pi there's my radius
right and then here's my height
function okay the reason i can justify
this
is by saying i would make a statement
about due to the symmetry of
r i can take this volume and double it
rather than considering the whole thing
there's a bit of a longer way to say it
and you can have a look at my um full
writing if you're not sure about the
wording okay but i didn't actually put
mics on there
because i would have put like half half
but i don't do half okay
right so from there i can take out my
two pi i can tidy this up a little bit
gives me the integral
right like so two pi 1 to 2
4 x squared minus x to the fourth
dx and now i'm integrating okay so there
was nothing from here to here there's
not much consequentially
but when you actually do integrate there
was the second mark there
okay so oops sorry i missed something
i missed something like i said because
of the symmetry of r you've got to
double
this volume right that'll give you the
whole thing this is just zero to two
one half so if i slap a 2 out the front
that'll give me the whole volume so this
actually should be a 4.
okay so i get 4 pi i'm going
integral let's see 4x cubed on 3
x to the five on five there was your
second mark
one actually integrated your third mark
was in here on the actual evaluation
okay now because because you were given
the result and this happened again
and again your actual results down here
right
okay because you were given this result
if one mark is here and a second mark is
here
you cannot expect a third mark for free
for writing down what you already know
okay so therefore this line in here
where you actually evaluate the upper
and lower bounds
is important vitally important right
and so what do you got there here four
pi
outside of you should get four thirds
minus the fifth
sorry what am i talking about uh four
times eight thirty
two on five minus zero
okay i wasn't too fast if you didn't say
zero minus zero i think that's okay
it's clear that it's zero but at least
you evaluated it and then out comes your
number
okay three marks one two three on the
actual evaluation